Speaker 1: Speaking of conspiracy theories, I
want to talk now about FOX host Maria BARTIROMO.
Back in January, a Republican gave Maria the
idea that there is going to be a mid-term
COVID variant. The idea being that this is a
contrived imaginary variant meant specifically
for Democrats, I guess, to jump. Justify new or
returning mandates related to the pandemic and I
guess somehow help them win in November. Although,
I'll be honest, I don't even know how a midterm
variant would help Democrats in the sense that. If
all of a sudden you need lots of new restrictions.
And it's Democrats that are in power. Wouldn't
voters say, oh, look, Democrats have failed
us because we've got to do restrictions
again? It doesn't even make any sense to me.
But Maria BARTIROMO likes it. So here's where she
first got the idea. This was during an interview
in January with U.S. Senate candidate, the
current Missouri attorney general, Eric Schmidt.
He seemed to have kind of given her the idea of
a midterm variant and she liked it. Take a look.
Speaker 2: Back with the AG of Missouri, Eric
Schmidt. And AG, you also questioned the timing
of the mandates and why he circumvented Congress
and put it all on OSHA, which doesn't have such
legislative authority. No. And I think that's
exactly right. You think back here. Joe Biden had
taken this off the table. He had said many times
that he wasn't going to have a vaccine mandate.
Afghanistan happened, which is perhaps the
worst foreign policy disaster in generations,
a betrayal of the American soldier, billions
of dollars of equipment left behind, a total
disaster. And then immediately after that, to
change the narrative, he announces these vaccine
mandates which are clearly unconstitutional,
unlawful. And, you know, why did the Supreme Court
agreed with us in court last week? But I think it
was a distraction and a cynical one at that. And
the American people deserve better. But look, this
has never been about the policy. This is about
power and control. And they're going to continue
to do this. You watch, Maria, the things that he
can't get done legislatively. He's going to
continue to move forward administratively,
whether it's on, quote, unquote, climate change.
We've got an existential threat. We've got,
you know, all these we're at a tipping point. He's
going to charge the deputy undersecretary of the
EPA who's not accountable to anybody to do these
things. And we're going to push back. If he can't
get federal, you know, he can't federalize the
elections, there will be a midterm variant watch
that's coming where he empowers administrative
agencies. But the good news here is the states
are going to continue to fight back to protect
individual rights and help save this country.
Yeah, I think you're right about that midterm
election variant and it's a great point.
Speaker 1: So there was Maria
BARTIROMO first getting that idea
and now she's repeating this constantly. I'm not
going to play all five or six examples of it for
you, but here is one from her show two days
ago. This was from her Fox Business Mornings
with Maria program. Here she is now. She's taken
this midterm variant thing hook, line and sinker.
Speaker 2: We don't know the extent of the
investigation yet, Maria. And I think the reason
for doing this, the reason this guy has stepped
in and put up millions of dollars to take care of
Hunter Biden, bailing them out once again is that
it's pretty embarrassing for the president of the
United States to have his son go to jail. I mean,
the bottom line, they do probably have a cause
for indicting Hunter Biden and putting him on
trial. And nobody on the left wants to see that
happen. But I have to say, this whole thing,
I mean, I think when Republicans take over
control of Congress, which I hope and expect to
happen in November, I think there's going to be
a lot of investigation of really what has gone
on here. Where does all this money come from?
If Hunter Biden has been making so much money
on Ukrainian and Chinese and Russian deals,
how in the world did he not pay his taxes? Why did
that happen? Why was he lying to the IRS? Because
that's basically what you're talking about. I
think it's astonishing that all this has gone on
and the liberal media continues to be completely
uninterested in the story. Yeah, well, you said
when the Republicans take over, how about if the
Republicans take over? Because The Washington
Post is reporting more COVID is on the horizon in
the fall, as I've been predicting the midterms.
Speaker 1: They're okay. The midterms very.
All right. So let's break this down in pieces.
First and foremost, have Democrats created any
variant? Of course not. No, that's absurd. Are
there more and more COVID cases? Yes. In
fact, COVID cases are spiking dramatically.
I'm not necessarily saying anything in particular
should be done. I'm not giving you my medical
opinion because I'm not a doctor. What I'm
telling you is COVID cases are increasing
dramatically. The U.S. was down up to about
28,000 official cases a day in late March.
The U.S. is now all the way back up to 70,000
cases a day. And with so many people not testing
at all or testing at home and not reporting that
they're sick, the real number of infections could
be two or even three times as high. We might
already be back up to somewhere between 150,000
and 200,000 cases a day. Am I saying that
we should do anything differently? No,
I'm not saying anything one way or the other.
That's for medical experts to decide. But
cases are spiking like crazy. That's number one.
Number two, Maria BARTIROMO seems to be suggesting
that it is the Democrats that come up with
strategically timed, contrived stories or issues
meant to benefit them in elections. But the
truth is that it's Republicans who have a very
long history of doing that. Ebola in 2014.
I remember reporting on it eight years ago
leading up to the midterm elections of
2014. I remember covering Rand Paul. I
remember I remember I see myself sitting
in the old studio covering these stories.
Republicans were going crazy about the
Ebola pandemic, which was essentially
contained in West Africa. I think that there were
between two and four cases that got to the U.S.,
one of which died, and they didn't even catch
it in the U.S.. I don't remember the details,
but we're talking about numbers. You can
count on one. And I told everybody this
issue disappears the day after the midterms and
we never heard about it again after the midterms.
That was a contrived issue by Republicans.
Another example, the migrant caravans. Every
time we start getting close to an election. Fox
News Migrant Caravan is departing in Nicaragua,
heading all the way up to their expected at the
US-Mexico border six weeks, eight weeks from now.
Democrats aren't doing anything about the migrant
caravan story is a contrived issue, with the
timing meant to help Republicans in elections,
midterm elections, in general elections,
voter fraud. Again, that was timed starting
six months before the 2020 election to have
a very particular effect, which I won't even go
into now, because you all know about it already.
It is the Republicans who do the carefully
and deliberately timed fake issues a a midterm
variant. What we have is another COVID spike
and why we have it and what should be done are
not the topics for this segment. But the idea
that Democrats have created that in any way is
completely absurd. And the really sad thing is
I've said it before. Maria BARTIROMO used to be
a good financial reporter 20 years ago. When I
first got into following the stock market, I'd
watch her on CNBC in the morning before school.
She really was doing good financial reporting.
She's become a conspiracy, not Trump brown
noser. And it's a really a shame. It really is